[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Sandow senior NFL writer for the
athletic boy he's got a I got a look at
all of these Pages here I got my
quarterback rankings NFL quarterback
tiers
um so I think we have one through four
and we thought uh well Mike go through
the process here what's the rationale
for how you rank these quarterbacks
so really about 10 years ago
um is when this project started it was
really just me learning from people in
the league how they evaluate them once
they're in a league and so uh you know
if you're a tier one quarterback you can
probably win without as much help as a
tier two three four quarterback so
Patrick Mahomes is the ultimate right I
mean they've been mid or bad on defense
they've been all over the place on
special teams they trade Tyreek Hill
they don't have a great run game shoot
Mahomes has a high ankle sprain he still
puts it on his back wins the whole thing
that's the ultimate measure of being
able to do it with less help whereas I
think if you get down into tier like
tier three you know Kirk Cousins has
been in there a lot or Andy Dalton was
or Jimmy G you feel like your team has a
chance but a lot of things got to be
right you know maybe we're a top five
defense and if you're worse than that at
a quarterback we're talking 2 000 Ravens
defense you know to really do it so
that's really the the lens that we're
looking at them through and so if you
look at tier one it's Mahomes unanimous
and then burrow and and Josh Allen Aaron
Rodgers and Justin Herbert
I'm taking a guy like Justin Herbert not
a lot of Team success but they're a
bottom five team on defense and special
teams they have no Run game and they
have a winning record
probably has something to do with the
quarterback and so that's kind of how we
do it and it's really a lot of fun I've
learned so much over the years doing
this and I think it's I think it's
getting better but do you there there's
some Anonymous people who are involved
in this giving you information I'm
curious if if Mahomes has a weakness is
anybody willing to speak publicly about
that
well funny you you mentioned that so
last year when I did this there was one
tier two vote for him and it caused a
fear I think Andy Reid was asked about
it you know I'm sure those guys use
every little thing for motivation
there's not a lot of criticism of him
but I think it was you know yeah like
even in this piece it was talked about
the next level from homes is really
um getting to a Rogers level in terms of
manipulation of the clock uh calling of
the timeouts maybe knowing when to give
up on a play like if you watch Rogers I
used to love this in Green Bay
uh they'd be off of a sideline him and
LaFleur and leflore would be like lost
in time in his call sheet all the
stuff's going on Rogers is chatting up
the referee in a first name basis Rogers
is watching the clock you know they get
it down and then Rogers is the one do it
right like like well he runs everything
he's winking at Luke Kuechly before the
play or whoever he's in charge of
absolutely every aspect and so I think
as you get more experience like I like
my homes
um will even get better in those areas
I'm also wondering about like Jordan
love to me it's kind of incomplete so
how do you how do you rank somebody who
really hasn't given us much yeah so if
you get down to tier four there's two
ways you can be a tier four quarterback
one not enough information so that's
Jordan love all the way he got 49 out of
50 votes in tier four you could make the
case why even have him in there well
he's a starting quarterback for the
Green Bay Packers he's played a game or
two and we put in some comments what
people's impressions are of him but for
the most part he's just gonna be a tier
four quarterback this year and then and
my home started out as one too he had
remember when Mahomes had one start
people loved him but we're not really
evaluating love in the same way as the
others so next year love hopefully we'll
start at a full season and we'll have a
a little bit of a clearer picture so yes
very much tier four is going to be
Jordan love you know Kenny Pickett uh
Desmond Ritter Sam Halloween how the
heck could we have any sort of an eval
on them we're not saying they're bad
because they're down in tier four we're
just saying we don't know how close are
Herbert and burrow
well burrow rocket had passed all those
guys so Borough was 49 out of 50 votes
in tier one and Herbert was 29 out of 50
in tier one so
you know the lack of Team success for
the Chargers and then specifically
blowing that lead I asked a couple of
these guys you know there's eight GMS
there's 10 head coaches there's 15
coordinators 10 that are Executives a
few other coaches well what would
Herbert have to do to win your tier one
vote and the answer was really hey make
one play you know you're up 27 to
nothing you got to make a play to win
that game you can't lose that game
conversely on the other side Trevor
Lawrence came back from 17 on Dallas
comes back 27 on uh on uh on the
Chargers he vaulted up into into tier
two and is now some pretty heady
companies so some of those big moments
in big games can
you know can't color it a little bit for
some of the voters but when you talk to
50 it sort of all evens out we're
talking to Mike Sandow senior NFL writer
for the athletic and his list is out uh
the top tier quarterbacks also when you
start to think about MVP odds and and I
do like
um where sometimes you look at that guy
and we don't know if he's ready for the
next step and then he takes that next
step I know Justin Fields is getting a
little too much love for me uh because
you got to win and if you're not going
to be a playoff team you're not going to
be an MVP but the thought of Justin
Fields as sort of what is he uh who is
he especially for that team
so I think 10 years ago if I had if he
was in this thing 10 years ago I think
the reviews on him would be more
negative I think people would be looking
at the flaws as a password which
everyone acknowledges and say sorry you
can't do it in this league unless you
can do that now I think what we've seen
is a little bit of a path forward
through through a jail and hurts uh you
know there's been a couple quarterbacks
that have that have had some success and
grown into something from being a really
unpolished Pastor early on so the makeup
of Justin Fields I think is positive for
him I mean I think everybody thinks he's
really smart he works really hard he's
diligent but you're right there was
certainly a sense among the voters hey
let's pump the brakes on the hype
because he really struggled throwing the
ball and ultimately
being able to handle the kind of the
pure passing situations is a component
of the upper tears especially tier one
because the game gets reduced to that
the other stuff melts away I don't care
how great of a runner you are when you
play in a playoff game against a good
team they're going to take that away or
late in the game you're down 10. you're
gonna have to throw the ball from this
spot in the pocket and so his Ascension
is going to determine depend on that and
he hasn't shown he can do that
why is there the fascination with Dak
Prescott that the national media has
uh yeah I to me so Jack's been in this
whatever five or six years he's just
been like the same every year I mean for
the most part he might have started out
as tier three and I think Dallas is part
of it and then there's you know the last
couple years they've had a good defense
and they haven't pushed far in the past
but their records good
I think the playoff stuff but you were
just talking Mike about in the moment
can you make a play that's what the
playoffs comes down to especially at
that position and that has not made that
play
yep he has not elevated them when
they've needed to and then
you know it is a small sample size but
you've got to do it now you lose to the
49ers I mean that's a tough defense so
you know but he I think he has a hole or
two in his game and that's why he
doesn't go higher there was a time a
couple years ago I thought he was going
to make that jump didn't he seem might
even before that injury it just seemed
like he was close and he just hasn't
done it for whatever reason so I think
he clearly needs
more around him than some of the other
guys that are higher than him
how do you look at rookies
we don't even put them in here because I
think the evaluation and projection of
from college to the pros is such uh crap
shoot and I and I don't mean that
disrespectfully to people who know who
to how to evaluate and all that but you
can get opinions all over the map I
leave them out because
when you talk to 50 people in the league
there's a ton of them who didn't even
look at the rookies their team wasn't
going to take them they're not even
familiar with them a lot of the coaches
in particular so I I think you have to
have played
uh to in the NFL to be evaluated for
this
give me what Aaron Rodgers doesn't do
well now that he used to do well and and
what the Jets are going to get at that
position
he's probably a little less Dynamic with
his legs and ability to escape I think
that's probably the one thing I think
everything else he can still do one of
the interesting things about the little
nuggets that was in there to me that I
hadn't thought of was he's playing 14
games on Turf this year he played Four
last year so when you think about Aaron
Rodgers
uh and when you think about him getting
hurt you think kind of calf injuries
lower leg maybe getting slammed down on
the turf in Minnesota those types of
plays and he's going to be 40 this year
you know so the wear and tear of that
surface in that Division and just to to
be able to hold up with maybe some
uncertainty at the tackle position you
know a new system maybe some breakdowns
not everyone on the exact same page that
would be my concern is just the the
whole season and still being good in the
playoffs because when he is healthy
um I think he's still Elite tier one I
think he can do everything
I'll leave you with this Steve Young was
with us last week and he said that he
this would be the era for him if he was
playing now because you've got to take
advantage of these yards you got to run
you have to have that ability he said
the days of Dan Marino and Peyton Mann
and Peyton Manning are over yeah we
won't have quarterbacks like that in the
future
totally I agree I mean there still could
be one or two I mean Joe burrow is
somewhat of that but uh I think if you
look at tier one now compared to 10
years ago it's the ability to create off
platform and off schedule that is a part
of these guys games that we almost take
for granted almost all of them right
Mahomes uh Josh Allen certainly Justin
Herbert and I do think that is different
and if you look at the top two tiers
which I have felt like if you got
someone in the top two tiers you feel
like you could go to win the Super Bowl
almost all of them can make a second
play like a reaction play almost all of
them and so that's when people say hey
how come Jared Goff isn't higher well
maybe he doesn't get his due but it's
got to kind of be set up for him he's
he's not going to create that second
thing so I totally agree I think Steve
Young also this generation the coaches
are more adaptable I think it's you're
going to get fired if you have your
system and don't adapt it you can't get
the quarterback so now they will work
with somebody and give them a chance
Jalen hurts never would have probably
made it
and now he makes it yeah I agree also
where you go it almost is beneficial for
a quarterback to go later because he'll
go to a better team because I've said
this before Patrick Mahomes was in
Chicago he'd be a curiosity if Jalen
hurts played for the Bears he'd be a
curiosity they play for really good
teams and then when you add something to
those really good teams that's where you
get magic
yeah having the time does hell but
you're the the coaches are so such an
important part I mentioned Goff a minute
ago think about from Jeff Fisher to Sean
McVay and now Ben Johnson or think of
guys that are with Kyle Shanahan it
makes such a huge difference in their
ability to not have to do it all maybe
you even have a plan for him in Kansas
City where my home sits behind an
ultimate Pro and Alex Smith you know
that's the sort of thing that so many of
these guys flame out uh because it just
doesn't work out for them and they never
really have a chance great stuff Mike we
appreciate your time have fun this
upcoming season thank you
thanks Dan That's Mike Sando senior NFL
writer for the athletic